[Music]
hello YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is guns on here welcome to my
eighteenth episode of dirty chest tricks
against Sicilian today I'm going to show
you a game of GM napalm Nishi where he
crossed a 2700 rated GM as well as
Sicilian dragon in just mere 23 moves
the good point I like about this tricky
line is when you check in database there
are very few games available in this
line that means you can literally use it
as a complete surprise weapon in the
tournament practice the opening arises
after the following model evil c5 Knight
to f3 d6 d4 and here black can take on
d4 or play Knight to f6 attacking on e4
and after Knight to c3 defending we
transpose back to the main line with see
captures d4 ok on Knight captures d4 and
now the trademark dragon mu g6 planning
to play Bishop to g7 and castle on the
Kings side well for the few moves both
players follow the main line white
continue with Bishop to e3 Bishop to g7
now f3 stopped Knight to g4 idea and
after Knight to c6 the obvious move
Queen to d2 planning to long castle okay
black castles and now rather than
playing the move Bishop to c4 with stop
defy by black white decided to play the
second alternative
namely castle on the queenside since
white hasn't committed Bishop to c4 and
allowing black to play the move defy
none of the good Sicilian player will
miss out and accordingly as per the
theory defy has been highest Lee played
mu in this position
well we have reached one of the critical
junction of this line as I highlighted
over here white has tried various
responses such as King to be one Queen
to even and taking on defy however
napalm the she come up with this very
strange idea he started with night
capture c6 which at first sight looks
very strange as after we capture c6 you
are not only allowing black to
strengthen his centre but the open B
file can provide a good counter-attack
for the black side however napalm Nicias
big idea is he wants to play Bishop 2 at
6:00 and getting rid of the powerful
dark square Bishop so you can already
see the position is bit tricky as if
white managed to get rid of this dark
square Bishop then g4 h4 h5 are
definitely on the card and not only that
meanwhile there is ongoing pressure on
the d5 square which all together create
some great headache for the black camp
for example if black tried to support
here with either the move Bishop to b6
or e6 then he faced this huge problem
Bishop captures g7 King kept his g7 as
soon as that Bishop disappeared from the
board
black attack on the B file has been
completely neutralized and not only that
what has this great fast follow up
starting with g4 and you can see the G
and H file pawns are strumming in to the
King side
and I think it is only black who will
find himself at the trouble zone so no
that's not the right approach and that's
why highest Lee played move in this
position is Bishop captures at six and
after Queen captures at six
as the d5 point is still pinned down
Queen to b6 is the choice when most of
the black players reach to this position
so idea is very obvious not only black
is unpinning this D pawn but he wants to
create this counter-attack immediately
with rook to b8 and then pressurized to
be to pawn okay that's fine but white
has cooked up something very fascinating
and here
Napo springs this big surprise if I
attacking the knight if Knight to h5
then g4 is a very strong reply so more
or less black is obliged to play the
only move Knight to d7 pressurizing the
e5 pawn and in some lines Knight can
reroute for the attack on the Queen side
so you can see up till this point the
play is pretty much forced and there is
no surprise that white will churn out
this obvious move H full continue the
merry journey with h5 and then made on
that file well believe it or not but
here black has the only move Knight
captures ePHI but after that I think
it's only engine who can defend this
position the more and obvious human
approaches rook to b8 creating a counter
immediately but unfortunately for black
hey straight away fallen into White's
tricky territory from now onwards every
single move is pretty much forced and
gives by a completely winning
first he defended the beat upon faith
Knight to e4 which accidentally also
hitting the Queen and blacks obvious
response Queen to b4 completely fails
due to the following move yup you
guessed it at 5 hand black even can't
touch this night if a careless black
opponent take this night then this is
the last time he's going to play the
dragon as after edge captures g6 the
mate is unavoidable on the edge file
here to be honest
this position is almost undefendable
let's see how a 2700 tried to defend and
still cannot save his king black played
defy the obvious move which cuts the
communication between rook and queen but
now white initiative run like a bullet
train Bishop to d3 another making threat
and black has to play another pawn move
namely fi so you can see already black
has weakened his King severely by
playing those pawn moves and it is
wonderful to watch
napalm Nicias preparation over here as
he continued wait Queen captures GF
attack and after King to h8 now comes
the important point of playing the h5
moon white deliver this dazzling
attacking moon rook to h4 so not only
defending the knight but in some
instances this rook can swing to the G
file and then black king is a complete
corner there another big point about
this rook lift is
black can't even move the Queen as for
example let's say he continued with
Queen to be seven then white has this
very nice reply at six
threatening a checkmate and after the
only move rook to g8 Queen captures e7
and the idea is very simple Bishop
captures fr and then deliverer made on
at seven well even after the best
defense such as night to see Phi which
tried to dislodge the Queen by giving a
knight still doesn't work because of the
following sequence Queen to f6 Jack rook
to g 7h captures g7 check and after
Queen captures g7 well you can take the
Queen and then take the Nile with a
clear piece advantage however White has
this dazzling sacrifice here yup it
start with falling variation Queen to d8
check Quinn to g8 and now rook captures
at 7 deliver a complete mop-up job after
King takes Andrew kachu and check black
King has to come on the G file so that
after Queen to f6
it's a lovely deciding checkmate so you
can see why it has some fascinating
lines if black moves the Queen of a and
rightly so in the game black played the
moon d4 which shut downs the door for
the rook and now try to grab the night
but unfortunately white didn't give any
time to the black camp the second DES
link blow occurs over here with Bishop
captures fi so not only removing the
dangerous fi pawn but there is a Jack
unleash on the default pawn and no
matter however black wriggles his game
cannot survive much longer
I want to stress that if black continued
wait rook captures f5 then again that
will not stop while to finish the game
as after Queen captures a fire Queen
captures e4 White has this nice move
Queen to f7 with the obvious threat at
six and then two mates exist on the ball
which can't be even defendable finally
in the game black probably fed up with
this position and made the ultimate
blunder Queen captures a foe which at
first sight looks so cool in fact after
this move there is making three guys
let's see can you spot it are you ready
let's get start now in the game Naomi
she played the mo at 6 which is
inaccurate however if you find the move
rook to g4 congratulations
has this mu conforms that black king is
going to be murdered at the corner of
the border altogether the 21 move rook
to g4 and black and simply pack is back
and go that's it guys I hope you enjoy
and learn this wonderful attacking and
tricky line against the Sicilian dragon
remember at this point continue with
ePHI and when the knight move
immediately commence your onslaught with
h4 and as we see in the game if your
opponent continue with the obvious move
rook to b8 then after Knight to a4 and
the moon at 5 you can get some great
attacking victories in just within the
opening stage thank you for watching
this video feel free to like subscribe
and comment and I will meet you
my next episode very soon bye and take
care